dionne week-end les conservent l'eau en
bouteille pour préparer les repas et
pour donner à sa fille de quatre mois
il boit donc l'eau du robinet contaminée
au plan dit en mai qu'elle est présente
aussi des irritations cutanées et sa
peau et desséchées car ils se lavent
aussi avec cet os les problèmes ont
commencé il ya deux ans quand la ville
de flint a choisi de réduire ses
dépenses en s'approvisionnant dans la
rivière plutôt qu'auprès de la ville de
détroit
nos extrêmement corrosif s'est mise à
ronger les vieux tuyaux de canalisation
dans certains cas aujourd'hui
le taux de plomb dans l'eau est 20 fois
supérieurs à la norme
pendant que les autorités médicales
enquête sur les liens entre cette
contamination et de nombreuses maladies
observées à flint dont 87 cas de
légionellose
l'état d'urgence a été décrété et la
garde nationale a été dépêchée pour
distribuer des milliers de bouteilles
d'eau et de filtres chaque
c'est une tragédie qui aurait pu être
prévenue selon de nouvelles révélations
l'état du michigan a ignoré les signaux
d'alerté et cacher l'information à ses
citoyens une situation inexcusable et
inexplicable selon le président
américain barack obama
le gouverneur adjoint du michigan que
nous avons croisés lors de la
distribution d'eau potable refuse de
répondre à ces critiques pris pour une
infante canadiens que par des résidents
de flint ne peuvent pas boire des
excuses ont des accusations dit il
ils ont besoin d'eau potable une réponse
qu'il déçoit dire dans la connerie
lui qui avait déjà perdu toute confiance
envers les élus
il n'est pas seul cinq recours
judiciaires pour négligence ont été
intentés contre l'état du michigan et
l'ancienne administration municipale
le département de la justice américaine
enquête aussi sur qui savait quoi et
quand ajoutent sept représentants de la
nouvelle mairesse de flint élu l'automne
passé la contamination que l'on à flint
est devenue un scandale national aux
états unis mais remplacer la
canalisation est un projet de plusieurs
années qui va coûter des milliards de
dollars chaque jour des résidents
doivent donc aller chercher leur ration
d'eau potable jusqu'à nouvel ordre
et si philippe leblanc radio canada
flint au michigan